Hello, first thing to say
is thank you all for coming.
I should probably say that the turnout
today perhaps either reflects how amazing
my book is or the time of year and the
fact that everyone's starting to think
about productivity at
the start of January. So,
so welcome for the last,
uh,
just coming up to 10 years.
My life has been about obsessing
and thinking about the,
the subject of productivity.
I mean,
it started out because I myself had some
big holes in my own productivity and I
didn't do things particularly well and
I started to really go on a journey of
conquering that for myself and then
starting to falling into teaching other
people about what I learned and,
and teaching other people on how
they could start to develop their own
productivity as well.
So I'm going to talk to you about
some of the key ideas from my book,
how to be a productivity Ninja and
hopefully give you a few ideas and spark a
few thoughts that you can then take away
news practically to make some changes
to the way that you work.
So the first thing I want to talk about
is the fact that often there's a bit of
a fatigue around this whole subject
apart from obviously at the very start of
January.
Um,
and the reason for that is that I think
a lot of people have been familiar with
some of the key ideas and
techniques of time management.
You've probably been on some kind of time
management cause before just by a show
of hands who's been on some kind of
time management thing. Um, and uh,
keep your hand up if everything is now
fixed and it's all sorted and you're 100%
wonderful in the way that you
work. So I think, um, for me,
time management is broken, time
management is dead. And I think, um,
the flip side of that is to start to think
much more about the idea of attention
management. So rather than thinking about
how we manage our, our tie, our time,
when you think about attention as being
the most precious resource that we have,
and how can we get the best out of those
times that we have the best attention.
Um,
so I'm going to talk to you about nine
things that you can do that really help
you to make the best of your attention.
Have nine different mindsets,
nine ways of thinking that will really
help you to become a productivity Ninja
and really help you to move forward in
terms of some of those turning some of
those older time management ideas into
something a bit more modern and a bit
more based in the world
that we live in today. Um,
so the first one of
those is zen like calm.
So often when I'm asked to
talk about productivity,
one of the questions that I ask back
is when was the time that you were most
productive?
So just if you think for a few moments
about when was the last time that you
really felt yes, I'm really
on top of this. This is a
moment of key productivity.
Often when people think
about that question,
the one of the answers that comes up
a lot is when I was on a deadline.
So you're on this deadline, you've
got this thing to do, it's five,
it's got to be in at five o'clock.
You've got this deadline and everything
else in your life and everything else in
your brain seems to fall away.
And you get into what
psychologists refer to as flow.
This kind of state of being totally
in the moment focused one thing.
You're not thinking about what you're
going to have for dinner that evening.
You're not thinking about emails,
you're just totally you in that zone
working on whatever that thing is,
whether it's a document,
whether it's ideas,
whether it's a thing that
you're doing as a team,
but everybody's just kind of focused or
you're just really focused on getting
this thing delivered and,
and that becomes the only thing in your
world at that point. Um, now for me,
the problem with that is that
deadlines are really expensive.
They cost us in terms of stress.
We start to love the people kind of
getting out of the way of the camera that
love it. Um, so at deadline
we'll really, uh, you know,
it will cost you a lot in terms of stress.
If you're constantly in deadlines and
you're constantly using deadlines is the
thing that gets you over the line with
stuff and you're leaving everything to
the last minute and letting
the deadline push you forward.
Then after a while you're going
to burn out. Whereas really, what,
what is the deadline doing anyway?
So what a deadline does is it,
it brings you into this state of Zen,
like calm.
It forces you to say this
is the most important thing.
I know that nothing else matters.
And my contention is you can get to
that place of saying this is the most
important thing.
Nothing else matters without a deadline.
And what you need to do to get to there
is much clearer thinking in terms of
what's on my plate so that you're really
much clearer about your priorities.
So I'm gonna talk to you a
bit about how to get there,
but the idea is to spend as much time
as possible in this state of Zen,
like calm state of flow. And this
state of I'm working on one thing.
I really know what I'm doing. I'm really
clear and focused on that one thing.
This is how a lot of us do spend a
lot of time in work, which is that we,
our brains are just full of different
ideas. Um, does this image look familiar?
So we have this whole sense of feeling
overloaded and overwhelmed and we have
the sense of there's a hundred
things we could be doing.
We're not quite sure where to start.
Um,
David Allen who wrote the book getting
things done has this lovely line,
which is the mind is for having
ideas not for holding them.
So the problem is if you've got all these
different things going on in your head,
then it becomes very difficult to get
to this state of zen like calm cause you
just totally thinking, oh that email,
that thing. You know, your, your,
your brain is constantly moving
from one thing to another,
trying to work out where were the
biggest priority might be. Um,
in any given moment. Um, it never
used to be this complicated. So,
um, Peter Drucker talked
about this idea of um, uh,
knowledge work in the information age.
So moving from the industrial agents,
the information age and what Peter Drucker
was very concerned with was defining
knowledge work.
Um,
you all in this room are knowledge workers
and what that means is you add value
and you create value out of information.
That wasn't always how we worked.
So back in the industrial age,
you might have had a job that
looks something like this.
So there's a cake factory,
there's a big conveyor belt and there's
cakes coming down the conveyor belt.
You've got a big box of cherries and your
job is to put one cherry on each cake.
So you do that nine to five, you
put cherries on cakes, nine to five,
you have your break at lunchtime,
you have a break in the morning,
break in the afternoon,
you go home at five o'clock.
How many people in that job putting
cherries on cakes? Nine to five.
We'd be going home of an evening and
Thinking, Oh, the cherries today.
It just went crazy.
All sat there on a Sunday evening.
And you're thinking to, I have no
idea how it's going to go next week,
it's going to be mental. So
it's very easy in, you know,
that kind of a job to know
exactly what does done look like,
what does the end look like,
what does success look like?
Whereas in knowledge work jobs, it's
much more difficult and not as many jobs.
It's much more about
how we define success,
how we define those particular
things that that make the difference.
And you know,
maybe your viewpoint is slightly
different from your bosses viewpoint and
there's all these competing
priorities at the same time.
So really one of the hardest things
to really acknowledge and to, and,
and one of the things we really got to
take into account when we're trying to
get into this state of zen like calm is
this idea that we're similar Tennessee,
the boss and the worker all at
the same time. So by the way,
all of you have to put cherries on cakes.
That is part of what you do. Those,
those cherries on cakes are
the emails that you send,
the meetings that you set up.
The things that you deliver,
you are all putting shows on cakes.
And the trouble is you're also having to
decide what time should the shift start
today and how fast should the conveyor
belt pick be going and all these other
questions. And having to think
strategically about, you know,
what's going on in the,
in the wider world is that everyone's
thinking about healthy eating.
So maybe we should take these cherries
and make fruit cocktails with them
instead.
You know,
so we're having to make all these
intuitive judgments at the same time as
delivering on work.
So it was similar tendency of the boss
and the workers all at the same time.
And really getting into that,
that state of sunlight car I'm getting
to a state of being able to deliver in a
really focused way involves
doing that boss thinking first.
Like really getting to grips with and
defining what's on my plate so that I can
then make the best decisions in
that moment and do the best work
so slightly,
um,
sort of different energy to follow
ruthlessness to follow on that time.
It would be Ruth. So almost like the
opposite energy from sunlight car. Um,
so the second of my nine coaches, six his
ruthlessness and, um, a lot of people,
when I put this slide up,
they start to conjure up images of like
Gordon Gekko in Wall Street or, um,
Leonardo Dicaprio in the wolf of
Wall Street, kind of, you know,
bowling with dwarves and all this
kind of stuff. And it's like,
so I'm not talking about stuff
that is, um, you know, uh,
you know, sort of very unkind
or, or really aggressive.
But we have to really think
about ruthlessness in terms
of how we define tasks,
how we defined what we're working on,
and just our own mindsets
around all this stuff. Um,
so the first thing is to be
really ruthless with yourself.
Really start to really think about
how many things do I have on my plate?
What are the things that really are going
to make the most difference and what
are the really good things that I should
be doing that I'm going to say no to?
So, you know, most people are, um,
very well able to say no to the
stuff that doesn't really matter.
It doesn't mean that we don't sometimes
spend time doing things that doesn't
really matter, but it's, you know,
it's sometimes really the trick is saying
no to really good stuff as well. Um,
so Warren Buffett has a lovely quote,
which is the difference between successful
people and very successful people is
that very successful people say no to
almost everything. And for me, you know,
this sense of being really tight and
defined around your role and what you're
working on and saying no to stuff that
perhaps sounds like a really good idea.
Um, you know, learning the art
is, is really, really important.
Um, also just being ruthless with
ourselves. So recognizing when we are, um,
in that sense of procrastinating.
I'm so, you know,
who turns on Facebook or
whatsapp or Instagram on your
phone or on your computer
like you do. So getting ruthless
with how you manage yourself on that.
And I'll talk a little bit more about
how to manage, manage attention and,
and some of the stuff that we can
do and that I'm in a few minutes,
but really getting Rufus to put
ourselves in that right frame of mind,
that right zone for productivity
and really starting to,
to be strict with ourselves sometimes
to get the right kind of work done. Um,
and then this one is really key.
So I think for me,
I mentioned the beginning that time
is not your most precious resource.
Attention is your most precious resource.
So in the book I talk about these
three different modes of attention.
So I think we have three
modes of attention. The
first is proactive attention.
This is the two to three hours a day
where we have the best energy and the best
ability to do our best work. And so when
you really start to think about it and,
and, and track this stuff and
just reflect on your own work, um,
every period of time,
let's say a couple of weeks,
you'll start to notice real kind of trends
and sort of peaks and troughs in your
energy levels.
So there's a time when you're sat at
your desk and you feel totally able,
totally focused, able to do the
really most difficult stuff.
So that's proactive attention on
the other end of the scale. Um,
who's had a time in your day where perhaps
you're sort of looking at the screen,
you're scrolling up and down on the
email inbox or whatever, and you know,
it's like the lights are on,
but no one's home.
It's like four o'clock in
the afternoon and you know,
so that's managing time really,
while you're in the right place,
doing the right thing.
But actually you don't have the
right level of attention to do really
sophisticated work at that point.
Um,
and there's loads of science
behind this too, right?
So there's loser science around willpower
and willpower is a dwindling resource
each day.
Um,
so it stands to reason that there will
be a point in your day where you have the
best energy,
that proactive attention and also pointing
the day we have inactive attention
and the bit in the middle
is called active attention.
So that's just kind of the bit in the
middle of where you can do some stuff that
you can't do everything. There's certain
things that you can do during that time.
Another problem is that proactive
attention often comes at points in the day
where other people want to
take our attention away.
Other people want to
scramble our attention.
And so we have to get really ruthless
with how we protect that proactive
attention. Um, so if you think about it
as being two to three hours a day, um,
most of the studies that have been done
on this say that that's generally for
most people in the morning
rather than the afternoon.
There are of course exceptions to that.
Um,
but that morning time where people tend
to have that practice of attention is
also the time where it's like,
okay,
so I'm just going to spend this just
warming up for the day or like I'm in
someone else's meeting or like
something else is going on.
And so often there are so many forces
that can just take the attention away from
us from basically scramble our attention.
So getting ruthless with protecting those
times and knowing when those times are
key for you. Uh, so for example,
like personally I have a bit of a policy
which is I don't do meetings in the
morning and phone calls in the morning.
So like my morning is like the heads down,
proactive attention time and the afternoon
is the more kind of collaborative
time.
And that's kind of easy for me to say
because I control my own diary and I get
that there are lots of
other factors at play there.
But even if it's just looking at
one or two hours a day and saying,
I'm going to Ruth as you try and protect
that time. And that can make a big,
big difference. Because in my
experience, most of Sydney,
most of my best work
and what I observe in,
in everyone else that
they work with is that,
that proactive attention that the
stuff that you do in those one, two,
three hours of the day,
that that really makes a difference.
Like that's the stuff that
you'll get judged for.
All the other stuff really is kind of
filling in all the kind of emails and
conversations and everything else.
The stuff that really makes
you famous in your job,
the stuff that really makes it impacts,
tends to happen in those
two to three hours a day.
So the third one comes
about his weapons savvy.
So obviously a Ninja has to
have weapons and tools. Um,
it's fun to geek out and have,
um, uh, you know, lots of, uh,
interesting kind of conversations with
other productivity geeks about like
different apps and all this kind of stuff.
But like really we have to be
savvy about how we use tools,
how we make the best of
all the tools that we have.
So on the little iPad there,
you've got like a few different tools.
The tool I use most
regularly is called nausea.
Nausea is basically a to do list APP,
very sophisticated to do list APP. Um,
that really allows me to manipulate
the data within my to do list. Um,
really well. I can look at it by
the project view project by project,
what am I working on?
I can look at it by where am I
going to be to do certain things.
I can categorize stuff, I can put date
reminders and all that sort of thing. Um,
so just like slightly more functionality
than a lot of them were basic to do
list apps. Um, other ones you'll find that
things like to do is remember the milk.
Um, really good apps. Most of them
have a kind of freemium model as well,
so you can get most of what you need from
the kind of free version and then you
pay a bit more if you want the
kind of subscription version. Um,
but one of the things I'd recommend is
really thinking about having some kind of
APP, um, that you're going
to use for your to do list.
And that then synchronizes with your
computer, with your phone, with an Ipad,
whatever you're using, um, across
those different devices and platforms,
but gives you that ability to,
to really kind of prioritize and think
clearly around the work that you're doing.
Um, so thinking about if you're
going to use any apps at all,
think about what you're gonna use
for what I called the second brain.
So your own brain is not particularly
great at holding onto and remembering all
that different data. So having a second
brain where you put all that stuff out,
you know, out on the page as
it were, like inside the APP,
and you start to see projects and actions
and start to be able to kind of move
those things around and
prioritize these things.
And that's really the kind of best
use of technology that you can have.
There's loads of other really
useful apps that I use, but for me,
like getting really honed around
a really good second brain,
a kind of app for me, makes
the biggest difference. Um,
I want to just like for a few
minutes just about email. Um, so, um,
who loves their email inbox?
Just suppose show of hands.
So a couple of hands. Uh, so for me email,
it's one of those things that has just
sort of pervaded work over the last few
years.
Um,
I don't need to tell you that you get a
lot of emails and the email is annoying.
That's kind of a given.
Um,
so I've over the last few years
been a big proponent of a,
a thing called inbox zero. The idea of
getting your inbox down to zero. Um,
and I think that's often
misunderstood thing. I think, um,
the idea of inbox zero,
um,
is not that you have your inbox at zero
all the time and that like you spend
every minute of the day
when one email comes in,
you have to kind of bat it away
and like leave it a zero. For me,
it's more of a mindset that says email
is just the medium that we communicate
through. Maybe it's not actually
where most of the best work gets done.
So inbox zero is really a way of kind of
hacking that problem in order that you
can get outside of the
inbox as much as possible.
The real work for me happens
outside of the email inbox. Um,
even when you're communicating via email,
you know,
really what's the stuff that's
really making a difference.
It's the impact of those two
people having conversations.
And if you had that same conversation
face to face or had that constant,
the same conversation over the phone,
you'd still get to the same results.
So email is always just the medium.
Um,
some people get very bogged down in
the idea of like email is their job and
email is the one thing they need to be
doing. And for me actually like, you know,
amazing things happen when you start
to get outside of your email inbox. Um,
just a very quick overview.
There's a whole chapter in the book that
talks about how to get your email inbox
to zero. My company, you think productive
runs, um, three hour workshops.
And what I've tried to do is take that
three hour workshop and put it into that
chapter of the book. So if you
spend about 45 minutes to an hour,
just kind of reading that chapter
with your email in front of you,
and then about an hour going through the
stuff that it says your inbox will be
at zero. Like we did a, we did some, uh,
like stats over our three hour workshop
and we found that 96% of people in that
three hours left the room
with their inbox at zero.
So it doesn't take you anywhere near
as long as you think what it does mean.
Like for the most part, people have
their email inbox open in front of them,
but they're also working on lots
of other things at the same, right.
It's the same time, right? So like for me,
when you get really focused around
just email, you can actually start to,
you know, hack some of that stuff away,
delete anything that's older than,
you know, a few days or whatever. And
you really start to get to zero very,
very quickly.
Um,
next one I'll talk about is I'm a
thing called stealth and camouflage.
A Ninja has to be, uh, able to get
slightly off the grid at different times.
So the main part of this song, it's
about his tactical hiding. Okay.
So, um, you guys are very used to
working in a very kind of open plan,
open kind of culture.
Um,
I think there's some really nice
benefits to that for sure. Um,
it also has some limitations and one of
those limitations probably as you're sat
here listening to me, one of the
things you're thinking is, well,
it's all very well for him. He probably
like works Lowe's at the time on his own.
He doesn't have less people interrupting
him at his desk all the time. Um,
and you know, I get this complaint a lot
from people saying, you know, I just,
I really want to get my head down. I
really want to get into that kind of Zen,
like calm kind of modes.
But actually the thing that's really
stopping me is someone comes and me a
question and then I get loads, more emails
and loads of other stuff's going on.
Um, so really thinking about how we can
avoid that. And I often say to people,
you know,
if you're,
if you're feeling like you're
being interrupted the whole time,
make yourself just deliberately less
available for some people that's going to
work from a coffee shop around the corner,
finding little cupboard somewhere where
no one's going to find you a, you know,
whatever that looks like.
But just trying to again,
protect those two to three hours of time,
proactive attention,
time to really kind of get down and get
your head down and get really kind of
focused on things. And it doesn't have to
just be a physical thing as well. So, um,
stuff that camouflage in a more kind of
digital sense and both outlook and Gmail
both have a function of work offline,
which I think it's just a
criminally underused thing.
The amount of times I'll say to people,
do you use work offline?
And people don't tend to use it.
But just the idea of that is that you
can work on the stuff that's in front of
you. You can see the emails, you can
see the calendar, whatever it is,
but actually what you,
uh,
don't have is the kind of
new notifications coming in
and the new emails coming
in.
So just using that work offline thing,
really nice way to just kind of slightly
make yourself less available and
slightly kind of, you know, get into
more of a kind of focus mood. Uh,
this one here is an app called
forest, um, who's come across forest.
Any forest fans in a
few. Good, good. So, um,
Forrest is a really nice
little app for, for focus. Um,
so the idea is that you set a period of
time, says, let's say it's 20 minutes,
half an hour,
and you say,
I'm going to really get my head
down and focus on this one thing.
Often the thing that gets in the way it's
like is just, Oh, what's on my phone,
right? Let me pick up my phone and have
a look and see what's going on there.
And so what does is it starts to build
a tree. So you've got this 20 minutes,
half an hour, it's, it's building
this tree. If during that 20 minutes,
half an hour it,
you attempted to pick up your phone and
go and look at Twitter or Facebook or
whatever the tree dies, right? So,
so really kind of smaller. I think
all it's doing is putting one tiny,
tiny little kind of positive
reason to not look at your phone.
I'm in competition with all those kinds
of other things that are going on in
your head and it's remarkably effective.
The other thing about forest is that as
a company, they invest some of their,
their profits in planting real trees.
So you can actually get a real guilt
right from like the tree dying.
It's a real tree. You have to think about
it in that way. Um, but really nice app,
there's a whole new chapter.
The updated version of the book has a
whole chapter called stop messing about on
your phone.
And one of the things that it talks about
is basically treating yourself like a
kid. Um, for those two to three
hours of practice of attention.
So I have an APP on my android
phone, it's called quality time. Uh,
there's some other iPhone
equivalent to that of it as well.
But basically what quality time does is
it allows me to set scheduled breaks.
So in that schedule break, it's
like in, in that two to three hours,
these are the things that I
can now access on my phone.
Everything else on my phone
is locked for that time.
So this kind of two to three hours of the
day, I have no access to Google chrome.
I have no access to Instagram,
I have no access to Twitter.
All those things are locked down.
They are unavailable.
If I want to get them back,
then what I have to do is I have to
cancel the scheduled break and the clock
starts ticking. Five minutes, four
minutes, 59, four minutes, 58.
Usually as you watch
that clock ticking down,
it's got to get all the way to zero before
you're allowed to turn the thing off.
I'm usually, that's long enough
years ago. Ah, screw this.
I'm not going to sit around for
five minutes waiting for the thing.
So it just tends to be,
again,
just a nice piece of psychology that keeps
you locked away from those things for
those times and just gives you
that kind of extra focus. Um,
and obviously the more you
know basic version of that,
it's just using the airplane mode,
just using the do not disturb
kind of features of the phone. Um,
just to keep some of that stuff in a
more kind of stuff and camouflage kind of
mode the same. I think it can
be applied to people as well.
So actually just having conversations
in your team, you know, um,
like what's the time where I really
need to get my head down and focus?
What are the times when
you need to do that?
How can we kind of share
those responsibilities and
make that happen for each
other? How can we do that within
the teams? So just for me,
I feel like when I go into
organizations often it's,
it's really amazing to me how many of
those conversations are just left unsaid.
And it sort of builds up in
bubbles up intentional ever.
But really it never gets put on the table.
Like what's the expectation around email?
What's the expectation
around my attention?
Like people don't have those conversations
is as often as perhaps we need to do
that.
Um,
next one gets about is unorthodoxy I'm
just doing things differently thinking in
a very different way.
Um,
I think that's probably fairly self
evident coming into Google to talk about
that. But you know, just I, I
go into so many companies were,
what really happens a lot is that people
spend a lot of time looking at their
direct competitors, looking at the,
the direct market that they're there,
they're in or around and trying to get
inspiration from what everybody else in
their sector is doing.
And I'm a huge fan of just looking way
beyond that and just kind of thinking,
how would someone else solve this problem?
How would someone else do that
piece of thinking? How so,
how would someone else to
communicate those kind of ideas.
So thinking about it from them,
you know,
the point of view of someone very
principled like Malala or how would you
explain this problem to a really
curious intelligence six year olds?
So just thinking about those kinds of
different ways to approach that same idea
or that same piece of thinking
and coming up with a solution.
The other thing around, um, an
orthodoxy is experimentation. So, um,
I'm a big believer that all of us are
very stuck in ruts with our own habits and
the way that we work.
So a couple of years ago I did this thing,
I did 12 extreme productivity
experiments and one for each month.
And the idea was to just challenge
all of my initial assumptions around
productivity and the way I worked.
So I did things like one was
called flipping the nine to five.
So I worked five til 9:00 AM and then
clocked off for the day at 9:00 AM I did
the same five to 9:00 PM.
So I had the whole day and then
have my four hours of work.
And what was incredible
about that was, um, you know,
I only had four hours a day and I thought
I was like super focused and super
productive already.
But having these,
there's this limitation of four hours
really maybe think twice about some of the
things I was doing.
I think constraints is always a really
beautiful thing to really get us to a
much stronger sense of focus.
I still use some of the kind of lessons
from that one. Um, I also tried one a,
which was a working an hour a day,
seven days a week.
So literally like one hour bursts,
but seven days a week just to
see how that would feel. Um,
it turns out I was really
stressed for like post, uh,
you do need more than an
hour a day. Generally. It
depends on what you're doing.
I did one,
which was whenever I feel clear about
decision or I'm slightly procrastinating
about a decision,
I made that decision by the throw of dice.
So what that meant is I
had to come up with one.
I had to come up with basically like
a two or three or six. Uh, different,
uh, like answers to the question and
then, you know, so sometimes, you know,
if you're really stuck with something,
being forced to come up with six different
ways of thinking about it just helps
you to open up your brain and kind of
think about things in a different way.
The other thing about that one was it
was really amazing to be able to detach
ego from decisions. It's like, well, I
didn't decide that the dice did, you know,
three different thing. Um,
but just I think, you know,
I say that because not
necessarily expecting you to
go back to your bosses and
say, I just want to work an hour
a day. Um, but I think for me,
doing those kind of experiments from
extremity is a really nice way to then get
back to some kind of sense of normality.
But with new learning,
I think often learning comes from these
extreme things that comes when you're
outside of your comfort zone. Um, and I,
I learned so much by doing that and I
think we can do those things really simply
in our day to day, you know. So just
getting off the bus or the tube,
like a stop early and just kind of
exploring the area for 10 minutes before
where it just puts your brain
in a really different thing.
It gets you out of this sense of everyday
starts the same way and every day he
has this like certain rhythm to it.
So if you're someone that always gets
into the office and the first thing you're
doing is on your phone,
on your email,
like try having the first two hours with
no phone and no email and just see what
that's like.
Um,
if you're someone who usually solves the
thing by getting up a document on the
screen and try and doing it,
just pen and paper.
So sometimes just those really tiny
little changes in habitually how we work
could just make a huge difference to
the way we think about certain things it
takes when you talk about is agility.
So this idea of um,
a zen like calm and,
and a lot of the ideas around a second
brain and having autonomy around our work,
they can be really compromised
where suddenly there's a
big fire that we have to
fight. There's some big thing going
on and we have to react to that.
So I'd say around that is,
you know,
we have to be really aware of where
those things might be coming from,
but also having a really good
starting point. If you're not in,
if you don't feel right now,
like you're in some kind of big
firefighting emergency kind of modes,
one of the best things you can be
doing is really taking stock in,
like getting clear on what you are working
on because you know that some other
emergency will come along,
there will be another fire.
So like getting to a place where you
really know what you're working on and
getting real clarity around that stuff,
it makes it much easier
to drop those things.
It makes it much easier when your
boss comes in and says, right,
can you work on this for
three days? It's like, well,
I can drop all that because this
is what I was working on before.
We all agree that this is
the more important thing.
So getting that kind of sense of,
um,
sort of clarity and being
organized around your work, um,
is just the most useful thing at the
point where a crisis hits because it's the
time when you really
need to know what you're,
and being able to do that in a more,
in a way that kind of feels more, um,
you know, just more comfortable and,
and you're, you're more able to,
to know what you're going to leave behind.
Um,
it can often be a sort of point of crisis
that really where we really start to,
uh, just look at the small things and
kind of sweat the small stuff rather than
really kind of thinking much bigger.
So the other thing is just habitually to
really be thinking what could be on the
radar. Like really thinking about that
kind of future. Uh, you know, like, uh,
what might be coming up and anticipating
problems before they happen.
Usually just the best
way to solve problems is,
is to try and nip them in the bud and
not let these things become big things.
And the other thing about agility is
just to dispel the myth of multitasking.
I was talking about, uh, talking about
this with somebody just before we started.
Um,
a lot of the old time management books
you said talking about the holy grail is
multitasking.
Like do two things at the same time and
then you'll be much more productive. Um,
actually like all the science points to
the fact that it's really hard for your
brain to do to,
to thinking tasks at the same time.
So multitasking really
doesn't exist in that way.
And in the kind of stuff we're doing,
we need to focus much more on the idea
of mono-tasking like doing one thing at a
time,
doing one thing with focus.
And that can be as applicable to
the desk space in front of you.
So not having five different bits of
paper that relates to five different
projects when you're
trying to focus on one,
just like putting those things
in a drawer or to one side,
same with your desktop,
like who's got hundreds of different
open windows on your computer and like
hundreds of different, uh,
you know, like unfiled, uh,
things that kind of get in the way.
So really kind of getting
that focus around mono-tasking
not multitasking really,
really helps. A couple more
before we finish. Uh, mindfulness.
Um, so when I first read the book,
um, about five years ago, um,
I was really struggling to
find the time and the space to,
to do that cause I had a business to
run and all the rest of it. So like,
it was this thing that kept coming up
every week. I looked at my to do list,
it was like write book. I
was like, oh, I'm not really,
that's not really happening.
What do I need to do? So what I did
was something quite extreme. I, um,
I booked a plane ticket to Sri Lanka.
I found a beach shot that have no Wifi,
no phone signal.
I was totally kind of off the grid and
I went away to Sri Lanka and I wrote the
book and I didn't really have
very many conversations a while.
I was there with different people, um,
because I was just kind of on my own. Um,
but I did meet a Buddhist monk at the
bus stop and basically the Buddhist monk,
uh,
asked me to come to the monastery and
taught me meditation and it was a really
beautiful thing.
Like a meditation wasn't supposed to be
one of the characteristics in the book,
but I was there and I was writing the
book and suddenly I was having this
experience around meditation.
It's like this has to be in the book,
it has to be a thing.
And I thought it was risky in at that
point to put meditation and mindfulness in
the book.
And I was going to go into my corporate
clients and they're going to be like,
this is all a bit hippy.
We were, what's going on?
And what's happened in the last few years
is that the opposite is becoming true,
which is that mindfulness has
become such a saturation thing.
And you get all these really annoying
things on Twitter that say the one thing
you need to do to be a better leader,
meditate for five minutes a day. Oh, well,
if only it was that easy. Great.
You know? So I think, you know,
meditation is an amazing tool.
It's not for everybody.
And I think there are lots of different
ways in my mind that we can get to a
place of mindfulness.
Really. You know, for me,
my phone's has kind of
noticing your thoughts,
noticing the things that you might
be stressed about in that moment,
and starting to really understand
where your brain might be going in,
in certain things.
So you can get that just to be walking
lots and lots and lots of different ways
that you can start to really
understand your brain. Um, and for me,
the benefit of that is thinking about
this idea of the lizard brain. Um,
so, uh, the lizard brain is the Amygdala.
It's the part of your brain that gives
you this, this fight or flight response,
and often the things that become really
tricky for us to do or we start to
procrastinate over or we're scared about
because the lizard brain is having some
big response to it. So for example,
when I put a book out into the world,
my lizard brain is kind of saying to me,
don't do this.
And the reason for that is that
books are going to be judged, right?
People are going to write Amazon reviews
about them and you know people are
going to make judgments about what you do.
And that's a scary thing.
It's the same reason if you're going
to stand up and give a presentation in
front of a bunch of your colleagues
or even worse, a bunch of your bosses,
it's like, I'm going to be judged here.
This is just becomes a scary thing.
So recognizing that that Lizard brain
is Austin going to try and sabotage it.
It's going to try and get in the way.
It's going to try and give you a period
of procrastination rather than a period
of really useful work.
Um,
so when we start to recognize
that that's lizard brain thinking,
we can start to override it
and do something differently.
And for me mindfulness is one of the
best ways that we can start to get into
that,
that kind of place.
I think also mindfulness is just a really
useful thing to help us just take a
step back and realize how we've,
how far we've come. Um, so, uh,
this is always quite
good point in the year.
I think when people start to kind of take
stock of where they were last year and
what they want to do this year.
Um,
so just kind of taking that step back
sometimes and kind of thinking how far we
have Commonwealth, what we have
achieved. Um, a really nice, uh,
productivity tip that doesn't
feel like one is, you know,
once a week or on a kind of regular
basis. Right. Have done list.
So as well as your to do
list, right. A half done list.
It's a really nice empowering thing.
Um,
also just kind of overrides that
lizard brain thinking of like, oh,
I'm not capable. I'm feel guilty that
I've not achieved this, you know,
just gives you that kind
of sense of momentum,
which again fuels the next kind
of round of productivity. Um,
preparedness. Um, one of the things
I talk about in the book is, um,
an idea called the weekly checklist.
So this is a thing that you do once a
week where you just kind of take a step
back from all of the work that you're
doing and you prioritize just really clear
thinking. Um, and sometimes it,
one of the things I come across quite
a lot in businesses is people feel like
they don't have the time for clear
thinking. Um, it just feels like a luxury.
It feels like something that I'll
do when everything dies down or when
everything changes. Um, Henry
Ford has this amazing quote,
which is thinking is the
hardest work there is,
which is the probable
reason so few engage in it.
And I really love that quote
because I think for me, you know,
when in a knowledge work job,
our job is to add value and
create value attic information,
the way we think and really
quality thinking is the
biggest asset that we have.
Our brains are our biggest tool.
Um,
so taking some time to step back
and really look at your projects,
look at your second brain, makes sure
all that kind of stuff feels fresh.
I think sometimes,
um,
to do lists kind of fall apart and the
apps fall apart because we lose trust in
what the data is within those apps.
So we start to look at what's in
the APP and we start to go, oh,
I know there's more stuff in my head so
I don't quite trust the APP has being
the full record of everything that
I've got. And then we lose trust in it.
We stopped using it
and it kind of changes.
So really having that weekly checklist,
having that regular time where your only
job really is to interact with those
lists and really get clear
on what's on your plate, um,
is a really nice way of keeping those
things fresh and ultimately gives you more
focus. But there is a cost to that, which
is a little bit of maintenance time.
So just coming back and
using those checklists to,
to really make those
good decisions happen.
The other thing about preparedness
is, um, uh, the idea of, uh, our,
our biggest tool being our
brain, um, is basically sleep.
And this slide is just to indicate the
sleep is a good thing and it's really
good to get enough sleep. So I think,
um, when you think about your tool,
your biggest tool being your brain,
I'm getting good sleep and all's a
whole lot of other stuff. You know,
hydration's a really important thing
and stuff that we kind of know. Um,
I've just actually just finished
writing a book and called work fuel,
which is all about nutrition and
how to eat to have better energy.
Looking at the things on your plate
Scougal as you're doing a good job. Uh,
it's good. Um, but I think, uh, it's just
one of those really underrated things.
You know,
they're there.
I really couldn't find any books out
there that looked at nutrition and
productivity and kind of marry those
two things in a really specific way.
So I've been working with a
nutritionist called Collette Hennigan,
who is my nutritionist for a couple of
years to really put that into practice.
So that comes out in March.
And, um, I think, you know,
for me all of those things
that help us to fuel our brain,
whether it be nutrition, whether it be
sleep, whether it be hydration, exercise,
you know, mindfulness to
extent can do the same thing,
but just all those things
that are really important to,
to give us as much of that energy and
proactive attention as possible. Um,
and finally, just to say that, um,
acumen and Ninja is a
human but not a superhero.
So when you do a lot of the
stuff that's in the book,
when you really start to have a really
good second brain are really good, uh,
like loads of apps and
tools that you're using.
When you've really got the best kind
of productivity up that you have,
people will look at you across
the office and they'll say, oh,
this person just feels like a superhero.
Like they're doing all this amazing stuff.
You'll start to be really
valued because of that.
And often people will start to come,
you know,
how do they do like have they got
some kind of special super power? Um,
and really none of us have super powers.
We're all just humans but with good tools
and good ways of thinking and all of
that stuff.
Um,
and I think that's a really useful thing
to come back and remind ourselves of
regularly. Just this idea of being human,
not Superhero, um, cause well that,
that doesn't mean is
that we have limitations.
It doesn't mean that we need
to acknowledge that humanist
sometimes and not work
ourselves too hard,
too often because ultimately we're
going to risk burnout by doing that. Um,
and we also need to kind of recognize
that humans do need that time to kind of
refresh the Mojo a little bit and kind
of come back to who we are outside of
work and be a human being,
not just a human doing. I'm,
so for me that's a
really, uh, important, uh,
part of the whole productivity
Ninja philosophy really
is this idea of human not
superhero.
And I think productivity is one of those
topics that it would be really boring
if you could just systematize everything
and everything could just be done by
robots. And then it's all
kind of done. Um, you know,
there's no challenge in that.
For me.
I think the interesting part
of productivity for me is
that we all come to this
with all those kinds of weird thoughts
that we have in our brain. Um,
so I've done, um, with my podcast,
I have a podcast called beyond busy.
I've done about a hundred interviews
now with I'm often very high achieving
people and people often sort
of say to me like, what's the,
having done all that work and some of
these really long in depth conversations
with high achieving people.
Like what's the kind of commonality,
one of the things that these people
have in common? And I would say, well,
the only thing I can find that once
people have in common is that humans are
weird.
Humans are weird.
And we all come at all of our
work with a lot of, um, you know,
kind of mental baggage if you like. We
have a lot of thoughts and I had that, uh,
derail us,
try and stop what we're doing,
try and get in the way
of what we're doing.
And actually by coming back and
reconnecting with the humanness,
I think that's where we start
to recognize some those things,
overcome some of those things.
Um, and also, um, you know,
by doing that we start to realize that
productivity is a really amazing thing.
Like humans are amazing. Like
we do so much amazing stuff. Um,
and despite all those limitations,
despite all these things,
we can just do amazing work.
[inaudible].